[Music]
there are many books that exist on
creativity and it's about hey do this
take a hot shower take a long walk in
nature be in a pink room or something
what my co-author anthony brandt and i
really strove to do here was to figure
out what is below all of that what is
what is the basic cognitive software
that's running in the human brain that
takes ideas in and smooshes them up and
crunches them and it's like a food
processor that's constantly spitting out
new ideas the key is that humans are
really different from one another and
for one person taking a hot shower might
work and for another person a cold
shower one person works well in the
morning another person at night for one
writer they should go and sit in the
coffee shop where it's loud and another
writer it works better for them to sit
alone in their quiet office and write so
I suspect there's no single piece of
advice that's going to apply to everyone
and that's what we wanted to avoid was
that sort of thing instead we're trying
to understand what is it that's special
about the human brain that that allows
creativity to happen because when you
look at us compared to all the other
species on the earth we have very
similar brains I mean you know obviously
we're just we're cousins with our with
our nearest neighbors and all throughout
the animal kingdom it's a continuous
family tree but there's this one species
that has gone that does he's incredibly
we're in New York City right now and
when I flew in here it's like looking at
a motherboard that has risen from the
earth and when you fly over a forest it
looks the same as it did a million years
ago so we're running around the planet
doing something unbelievable you don't
have squirrels going to the moon or dogs
inventing the internet or cows doing
theater plays from one another or any of
the gajillion things that we do where
we're doing something really different
and and that's what that's what Anthony
and I have really tried to understand so
I'm a neuroscientist Anthony is a music
composer and we started talking about
creativity a while ago many years ago
we've been good friends for a long time
and we started realizing that there were
all these very interesting ways which
are view
came together so then we ended up
writing this book together what's
special about the human brain is that we
during the evolution of the cortex got a
lot more space in between input and
output so other animals have these much
closer together so when they get some
stimulus they make a essentially
reflexive response in humans as the
cortex expanded there's a lot more room
there which means that inputs can come
in and sort of percolate around and and
get stored and get thought about and
then maybe you make an output or maybe
you don't and there's one other thing
that happened with the expansion of the
cortex which is that we got a much
bigger prefrontal cortex that's the part
right behind the forehead and that is
what allows us to simulate what ifs to
separate ourselves from our location in
space and time and think about
possibilities what if I did that what if
what if I had done that what if I could
do that and so we do this all of the
time the amazing part is now there are
almost eight billion brains running
around the planet and as a result
creativity I mean the creativity of our
species has gone up in this mad amazing
way because there's so much raw material
to draw on and we're you know there are
so many of us that are causing saying
well what if this what is that most of
the things that we generate stink and in
fact only some fractions I'm even
percolate up to consciousness and of
those most of those stink but every once
in a while you have one that works it
actually sticks for your Society for
your moment in space and time and and
and you make the next step and so what's
happening now is we've got this
massively bootstrapping society going on
around us
you